small businesses are the engine of the
u.s economy the numbers tell the story
across the country there are more than
32 million small businesses generally
defined as any enterprise with fewer
than 500 employees that's compared with
20 000 large businesses which let's not
forget often started out small it's easy
to overlook how often we interact with
small businesses even when dealing with
the biggest brands here's how bill
dunkleberg of the national federation of
independent business explains it when
you buy a new ford f-150 you don't buy
it from ford you buy it from some small
business owner
so small businesses are the interface
between the production sector and the
consumer and for those keeping track of
the rise of the influencer culture there
are more than 25 million one-person
firms out there that's up nine percent
since 2018. if you were to count us
small businesses on their own they would
be equivalent to the world's third
biggest economy after the us and china
and here's why small businesses
contribute more than two-fifths of the
u.s economy they employ 40 percent of
americans and create more jobs than
their bigger counterparts making up
almost two-thirds of net new jobs since
1995. in the past economic downturns
often led to more people striking it out
on their own a lot of people lost their
jobs in various recessions they left
with a pot of money severance pay etc
and then they well you know i never
planned on going into business but
now that i've been thrown out of my
big business maybe i'll start my small
business so
that's been a major source of
entrepreneurs for a long time but march
2020 was different when kovit first
reached the u.s local governments
ordered the shutdown of all
non-essential businesses so any company
in the service industry relying on foot
traffic was hit hard especially
restaurants hotels and fitness clubs
more than two years later coveted
infections are no longer spiking
restrictions have been loosened and
people are more comfortable with
traveling and returning to the office
but the damage is pervasive
only 30 percent of small businesses say
that their sales have returned to
pre-pandemic levels in contrast the
stock market has more than recovered
since its bottom in march 2020. for a
lot of people their retirement
went out the window because their
investment was not in stock market but
in their company and people continue to
invest in their companies paying up to
deal with shortages caused by supply
chain issues and also contending with
higher prices for the cost of everything
from their inventory to employees
inflation is a problem of course costs
are coming in their back door and then
they have to pass it on through the
front door and so we see 65 or so of our
firms reporting that they raised average
selling prices and almost many plan to
continue to do that in future quarters
which means controlling your costs
becomes more critical than ever
technology is a big part of the solution
think of how businesses can connect
directly with their customers through
social media or open online stores
rather than spending on expensive
physical storefronts but sometimes
technology is more promising than
practical like with crypto as innovative
as the digital currency world is until
the government figures out regulations
most small businesses are still years
away from being able to accept payment
in crypto